la santé publique de toronto se penche
sur une éclosion de rougeole quatre cas
ont été confirmés aujourd'hui
en décembre dernier on a détecté 70 qu'à
disneyland aux états unis et la maladie
s'est propagée dans d'autres états le
problème c'est que de plus en plus de
familles décident de ne pas faire
vacciner leurs enfants alors
assisterons-nous en retour de cette
maladie on sent michel bonsoir c'est
pourtant si malade il faut pas prendre à
la légère c'est grave c'est très
contagieux oui absolument
alors si on regarde les chiffres avant
qu'on commence à vacciner la population
il y avait deux millions six cent mille
personnes par année qui mouraient de
cette maladie là et on a même mesuré que
depuis la fin du 19e siècle à aller
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est plus de 200
millions de personnes qui sont décédées
de la rougeole donc c'est pas de maladie
qu'il faut prendre à la légère mais
depuis on a fait des progrès incroyables
depuis que l'on va axer on a que 145
mille morts surtout dans des pays où on
n'a pas accès à la vaccination
donc c'est effectivement c'est un virus
qui se propage rapidement et qui peut
toucher 90% de la population est
pourquoi est ce qu'elle fait plus de
ravages chez les enfants que d'autres
maladies je pense à la varicelle par
exemple les oreillons
regardons ensemble et ça commence un
petit peu comme une grippe des symptômes
donc stefano di fiemme nez qui coule le
tout sur rouge mais commence à y avoir
des petits points blancs à l'intérieur
de la joue et ensuite une semaine plus
tard
là on commence à voir les rougeurs sur
le corps de façon générale comme ça que
ça sympa il ya des risques de
complications bien sûr absolument et
c'est là qu'on retrouve les décès si on
regarde ça donc en ces faillites
un décès sur dix mille personnes
touchées ça peut se transforme en oedème
cérébral des pneumonies peuvent causer
des décès diarrhée sévère et la cécité
c'est une excuse et moi c'est beaucoup
de décès c'est de 15000 à 60 mille décès
par année et est ce que le vaccin est le
seul remède entre guillemets possible
n'y a pas de médicaments
l'appelant et dicaments céline donc il
faut se faire vacciner pour se faire
vacciner à six mois deux fois dans le
célèbre vaccin rougeole oreillons
rubéole revenons à ce qui s'est passé
aux états unis alors comment cette
provocation s'est faite aux états unis à
partir de 19h oui absolument ben faut
tourner en 1998 quand il ya une étude
qui a démontré un lien entre le vaccin
de la rougeole et l'autisme alors là on
a paniqué pourtant l'auteur il ya
quelques années a dit non ce n'est pas
vrai j'ai fait une fraude et depuis ce
temps là on n'a pas arrêté de voir des
gens qui décident de ne pas faire
vacciner dans certaines écoles ou aux
états unis ça peut aller jusqu'à 40%
les parents qui décident de ne pas faire
vacciner leurs enfants et au canada
quelle est la situation moi ya ces
quatre nouveaux cas à toronto
aujourd'hui oui donc si on regarde l'an
passé il ya eu cinq provinces la
colombie-britannique l'alberta la
saskatchewan le manitoba et l'ontario
qui ont eu des cas normalement élevé au
québec on en a eu il ya quelques années
mais là ici au canada les taux de
vaccination sont assez bons donc il faut
se faire vacciner que c'est le message
que vous lancez aujourd'hui
oui parce qu'en fait les bénéfices ont
beaucoup plus élevé que les risques et
on ne veut pas revenir à ces périodes
sombres où on avait des millions
d'enfants qui étaient atteints de cette
maladie là ici céline il n'y a pas de
complot il n'y a que le bon sens
profitons donc de ce vaccin
merci beaucoup michel merci beaucoup le
seau d'eau